après son succès retentissant 2012
l'apprentissage profond aussi appelé
deep learning a commencé à envahir les
laboratoires de recherche en
intelligence artificielle les années qui
suivirent nécessaire de le confirmer
plus un réseau de neurones et profond
meilleures sont ses performances
voilà qui pousse à de nombreux
chercheurs a entraîné des réseaux de
neurones avec de plus en plus de couches
pour aller du dip leur nîmes vers le
very deep learning et pendant longtemps
à condition d'avoir suffisamment de
données il semblait que plus les réseaux
étaient profonds plus il était en effet
performant cependant il semblait y avoir
une limite à 7 déraisonnable efficacité
de la profondeur en effet à partir d'un
certain moment le dip learning sais
c'est de bien fonctionner à cause d'un
phénomène dont on a déjà parlé dans un
épisode précédent à savoir l'évanescence
du gradient ou vanishing louis dionne en
anglais oui parce que lorsqu'on applique
algorithmes de rétro propagation pour
ajuster les paramètres de nos modèles
l'intensité du gradient et x lespwa
synaptique des synapses entre les
coaches voilà qui fait que cette
intensité est démultipliée encore et
encore ce qui correspond à une
croissance ou de décroissance
exponentielle les gradients alors a
tendance à exploser dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
plus précisément si les pois synaptique
sont légèrement supérieurs à 1
alors on va avoir une explosion
exponentielle des gradients et s'ils
sont légèrement inférieures à 1
alors on va avoir une évanescence
exponentielle des gradients et ça ça
fait que même si en principe la descente
de gradient stochastiques pour des
raisons très profond devrait fonctionner
en pratique ça ne marche vraiment pas
les arrondis dénombrer les limites de
puissance de calcul font que la descente
de gradient ne mène nulle part
et pourtant il semble bien que la
profondeur devrait permettre d'améliorer
les performances
dès lors il s'agit surtout de trouver
des manières astucieuse d'entraîner un
réseau très profond à apprendre des
données malgré sa profondeur comment
faire une façon de faire consiste à
compiler des modules avec des feedbacks
intermédiaire typiquement si on veut
entraîner une machine à prendre un livre
et à comprendre le texte qu'elle lit on
peut d'abord entraîné son cortex visuel
à reconnaître un livre ses marques et à
identifier les zones de texte
typiquement avec un réseau de neurones
de convolution puis on peut entraîner
des modules plus profond qui récupère
les images des zones de texte et font de
la reconnaissance de caractères
ensuite on peut utiliser les caractères
pour les combinés en mots puis utiliser
quelque chose comme world check pour
calculer des représentations sémantique
des mots enfin on peut travailler avec
les représentations sémantique des mots
pour en inférer une sémantique des
phrases par exemple avec un réseau
récurrents elle estime comme ceux dont
on a parlé dans un épisode précédent et
on peut peut-être ensuite combinés les
phrases avec un autre réseau récurrents
et lestienne pour un ferrer la
sémantique de tout le texte de façon
cruciale
on peut entraîner chacun des modules de
manière indépendante en introduisant des
feedbacks intermédiaire potentiellement
guidé par de l'apprentissage superviser
un peu le cadre facile du machine
learning dont on a parlé dans l'épisode
ce faisant on n'a pas besoin de rétro
propager les gradients depuis le fond du
match les réseaux de neurones vers les
premières couches crie on évite ainsi
l'évanescence du gradient et l'analogie
semble d'ailleurs se tenir avec
l'apprentissage général il est ainsi
souvent utile de séquences et
l'apprentissage en plusieurs phases et
de travailler chacune des phases de
façon aussi indépendante que possible et
pour juger nos performances à chaque
phase il est alors utile d'avoir des
feedbacks pour chacune des phases de
l'apprentissage est donc l inverse si
vous êtes une personne en charge de
donner ce genre de feedback
il est peut-être préférable de mettre en
valeur un petit nombre de points précis
plutôt que de faire un long discours sur
l'intégralité des performances de la
personne que vous encadrez et peut-être
même que travailler un seul point précis
en oubliant tout le reste peut être
encore plus utile pour l'apprentissage
cependant parfois il est difficile
d'accéder à ces feedbacks intermédiaires
notamment qu'on l'apprentissage est
entièrement non supervisées ou lorsque
le superviseur ne comprend pas lui-même
les étapes intermédiaires pour vous
fournir des feedbacks pour adresser ce
cas les chercheurs en intelligence
artificielle se sont appuyés encore une
fois sur l'analogie avec la biologie en
particulier se trouve que le cortex
visuel en plus de posséder des coupes
vers 1 avait cinq comme déjà parlé dans
l'épisode précédent
ce cortex visuel possède aussi quelques
neurones centraux appelées cellules
pyramidale dont certains axones
permettent d'envoyer des signaux qui
sauteront plein d'étapes intermédiaires
et maxi axones sont des sortes
d'autoroute des réseaux de neurones
biologique
ok mais quelle peut bien être l'intérêt
des autoroutes et bien comme vous le
voyez là ça crée des chemins le long
desquelles le gradient n'aura pas le
temps de disparaître
ce sera d'ailleurs particulièrement le
cas si en plus on force
ces autoroutes à avoir des poids
synaptique quasiment égaux à 1 et outre
l'analogie avec un biologie c'est un peu
ça la motivation des autoroutes les
autoroutes permettent de remonter les
gradients sans les détruire
de sorte que même les premières couches
puisse déterminer des façons de
contribuer à l'amélioration globale du
réseau de neurones et réseaux de
neurones très profond avec de tels
autoroutes sont appelés des réseaux de
neurones résiduelles ou rays net pour
les intimes et si on considère que la
profondeur de tels réseaux et celle du
plus long chemin de l'entrée vers la
sortie alors de nos jours il existe des
réseaux résiduelles qui continue à
gagner en performance en augmentant le
nombre de couches jusqu'aux alentours de
1000 cet article de 2016 explique même
aller au delà de 1200 couche avec encore
des progrès dans les performances dans
le problème classique de machine
learning de reconnaissance d'image à
plessis par dix et depuis ces réseaux de
neurones résiduelles trouve de
nombreuses applications surtout en santé
mais aussi dans d'autres domaines comme
la sismologie
l'idée de ces autoroutes me donne
d'ailleurs envie de faire une autre
halte au logis encore avec l'écriture de
preuves mathématiques notamment
l'écriture de l'ong preuves
mathématiques dans un premier temps il
est utile d'identifier un petit nombre
de points de passage utile dans le
jargon
ceci revient et identifié d'hellemmes
s'il ya des espèces de théorèmes
intermédiaires qui sont plus faciles à
démontrer que le théorème globale et sur
lesquels on pourra s'appuyer pour
démontrer le théorème global est souvent
la première étape de l'écriture du nom
preuve après une petite réflexion sur
est-ce que ce théorème est vrai c'est
vraiment la recharge que celle m et
idéalement il faut que celle m e est
vraiment l'air vrai ensuite il vient un
moment où si l'on a de la chance on
parvient à séquencer la preuve en un
certain nombre de lem et de sorte que le
passager jiten l'aiment à l'autre semble
faisable voire facile
on obtient alors une pseudo autoroute
qui vont de l'hypothèse par la
conclusion du théorème il ne reste plus
qu'à tracer la route et pour cela il
suffit de construire chaque tronçon en
espérant qu'aucun ne pose problème
de la même manière il semble que notre
cortex visuel soit capable de ce genre
de prouesse il identifie d'abord une
façon globale d'interpréter des images
visuelles puis et capables d'affiner les
détails de son âne elle
pour une plus grande précision et de
façon plus générale il semble qu'il
s'agisse là d'une bonne façon
d'apprendre des successions de notions
très difficile il est utile d'avoir
d'abord une vue d'ensemble avec quelques
pointes et puis il est utile de se
concentrer sur chacun des points clés
pour s'assurer qu'aucun ne soit un
sophisme fallacieux bon après c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
la nymphe en a déjà parlé du cortex
visuel en parlant notamment des réseaux
de convolution et raphaël guillaume de
demande si de tels cortex visuel sont
également susceptibles aux illusions
d'optique il pense notamment à cette
fameuse image que je vais là où on voit
à la fois un canard et un lapin mais
jamais les deux en même temps en
fonction de l'avenir regarde cette image
alors si on prend la notion d'illusions
d'optiques de façon assez générale en
disant qu illusion d'optique
c'est quand on a une image qui
représente quelque chose mais on voit
autre chose
eh bien ça sur les réseaux de neurones
font ça c'est bien trop souvent on va
dire ça correspond à ce qu'on
appellerait aussi des erreurs de
classification donc il arrive très
souvent que montre une image un réseau
de neurones et qu'il appelle sa autre
chose est bon en général c'est assez
loufoque mais parfois ça peut être assez
assez problématique comme par exemple ce
cas d'une intelligence artificielle qui
lorsqu'on lui donner des images du vin
dont la couleur de peau était noir
disait qu'il voyait des gorilles bon
après on peut se dire que ce genre
d'erreur n'est pas vraiment le genre
d'erreur que font les humains or on voit
que du coup on peut se demander est-ce
que les illusions d'optique classique
des humains sont des illusions d'optique
que les intelligences artificielles sont
susceptibles d'avoir également et là la
réponse est sans doute oui notamment si
on en croit le cours de ce 1 et ce 2 e
du collège de france sur le cerveau
statisticiens qui explique que beaucoup
de ses illusions d'optique sont en fait
totalement expliquée dans un cadre bien
en supposant que le cerveau à des a
priori sur ce qui s'attend à observer et
qu'il n'interprète ceux qui voient en
fonction de ses a priori si on suppose
que cela est bien on a des certaine
façon d'interpréter certaines six
mariages qui correspond souvent à la
manière dont on les interprète aurait si
on les voyait dans une savane africaine
dans un paysage assez naturel et pas
créés en laboratoire et à cause de cette
âpre et veiller sur ce qu'on s'attend à
avoir on risque de deviner des choses
qui ne correspondent pas à ce qui est
véritablement donc typiquement l'exemple
classique de ça c'est le fait que nous
autres humains sommes optimisé pour
vivre dans des prix tribus primitives
notamment avec d'autres individus du
coup nous avons un a priori sur ce
qu'une voyante qui est généralement des
visages habitude d'interagir avec des
humains quand on voit une image on
s'attend à ce qu'ils aient une image de
visages l'intérieur sauf que bien sûr
quand on prend des photos d'image de
cailloux sur mars par exemple a priori
il n'y a pas de visage mais on a cet a
priori qui est que d'habitude quand on
regarde les images il y à des visages et
à cause de cet a priori a posteriori
quand on voit une image et surtout si on
sait pas que son image dans le caillou à
mars et qu'on contextualise pas assez
l'image est bien à ce moment là notre
cortex visuel fait qu'on pourra voir un
visage
bref c'est l'occasion pour moi de
mentionner un proverbe bayésiens dit que
sans conteste sans contexte c'est la
mauvaise probabilité conteste et bien
souvent les illusions d'optique
correspondent à raisonner avec le
mauvais contexte ne pouvait faire
demande aussi les intelligences
artificielles pour avoir des
personnalités multiples et une certaine
manière j'ai envie de dire oui très
probablement parce que au fur et à
mesure qu'elles sont déployés les
intelligences artificielles sont
répliquées copier coller est modifié
souvent localement nous par exemple
l'intelligence artificielle d'auto
complétion des mots est pas la même sur
mon téléphone que sur votre téléphone
sans doute et d'une certaine manière
c'est un rôle
la même intelligence artificielle
initial qui a du coup créer différentes
versions d'elle même et qui du coup a
une certaine manière de différentes
personnalités
ok c'est une façon je pense
d'interpréter ce que ça pourrait vouloir
dire de façon plus générale en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que on veut
absolument décentraliser ses
intelligences artificielles pour les
mettre au plus proche de nombreux
utilisateurs aussi d'autres raisons de
vouloir décentraliser les intelligences
artificielles et ça ça fait qui peut
avoir des copies différentes
mutuellement incompatibles en fait des
mêmes intelligence artificielle qui font
que du coup deux intelligences
artistique initialement les mêmes
peuvent se retrouver à être différente
de façon plus générale je pense qu'il
est utile de ne pas parler de
l'intelligence artificielle au singulier
il est utile de garder en tête qu'en
fait dans le futur est déjà dans le
présent il y a plusieurs intelligence
artificielle et il faudra plus fait
parler d intelligence artificielle
plutôt que de l'intelligence
artificielle le banc par abus de langage
savait pas trop gênant de dire
l'intelligence artificielle de façon
générale tout cas c'est un truc que j'ai
beaucoup fait dans cette série et
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
la production verra le dernier épisode
sur les architectures de réseaux de
neurones on parlera des réseaux de
neurones adversaire yeux qui est cette
architecture particulièrement génial qui
a conduit à des performances extrêmement
spectaculaires dans les performances des
intelligences artificielles et qui
s'explique que très très bien avec
défilement bayésiens donc c'est un truc
beaucoup pour voir la prochaine fois si
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
liker à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour l'épisode
merci un petit peu à peu leurs dents et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois pourquoi cette méthode à laquelle
personne ne croyait il ya encore
quelques années s'est mise à marcher
soudainement et bien comme souvent il ya
plusieurs raisons d'abord les
algorithmes ont progressé 1 comme
toujours notamment contrairement à ce
que je peux laisser penser on n'utilise
pas n'importe quel réseau profond - ce
n'est pas juste un tas de neurones
empilés et on a d architecture
particulière qui fonctionne bien mais qu
elle fasse pour moi est avant tout un
grand crac